[APPLAUSE]
PETER FETTERMAN: Thank you, Ben.
It's great to be back at Google.
I was reading one
of my favorite books
last night, which
I always do when
I get to interview someone very
accomplished and distinguished.
It's a book by
Viktor Frankl called
"Man's Search for Meaning."
And there was a
passage I reflected on,
which I think is very
relevant to today.
He said, "Don't aim at success.
The more you aim at it
and make it a target,
the more you are
going to miss it.
For success, like happiness,
cannot be pursued.
It must ensue, and it only
does so as the unintended side
effect of one's personal
dedication to a cause
greater than one's self."
Steve, what do you
think your cause is?
Pretty tough, beautiful words.
STEVE MCCURRY: No,
that's very profound.
My life has been--
I think it's been a dream.
It's been wonderful.
My ambition-- and when
I was 19, I left town,
went to live in
Europe for a year.
And I decided, after
spending that year wandering
around Europe, I wanted to
travel for the rest of my life.
I thought this was great
to go to new places,
new cultures, meet
new people, see
how things are done differently
in other parts of the world.
PETER FETTERMAN: Was it a
kind of escape from you,
from your environment,
from your home?
Did you feel restricted
by your upbringing?
STEVE MCCURRY: I had
a great childhood.
I was happy.
I had friends.
Once I started traveling,
I just realized
there was this big world out
there with incredible beauty
and architecture.
And I just wanted to see it all.
I wanted to go to
the Grand Canyon.
see the Taj Mahal.
I wanted to go to China.
I wanted to go to Africa and
see what's happening there.
PETER FETTERMAN: You had this
wanderlust from a young age.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
But I realized that
I can't just travel--
first of all, I had
to make a living.
But I needed some purpose.
I needed to find a way to do
something in addition just
to travel.
So I went back to school.
I fell into a film
course at the university.
And in studying filmmaking,
cinematography, I took a class
in still photography.
And it was at that point
the light bulb went off.
And I thought, this was the
way that I could potentially
travel, make a living.
So I basically got a job on a
newspaper for a couple years
in 1974, saved my money, and
got a one-way ticket to India,
and basically never looked back.
I left in '78.
And I've been basically
traveling ever since.
PETER FETTERMAN: Did you
have photographic heroes?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
that first film course
I took, there was a big library
with tons of photography books.
So I started poring
over all of these.
And I think that one of the
great pleasures in life,
as a photographer, is
going through past work.
And the work that really
spoke to me in a very deep way
was photographers like
Andre Kertesz, Walker Evans,
Dorothea Lange, Eugene Smith.
But I have to say, the one
that-- and Elliott Erwitt,
of course, who has
become a friend.
But the one photographer
who, in a way,
was head and shoulders,
for me, above all
the other photographers
was Henri Cartier-Bresson.
PETER FETTERMAN: What did he
have that the others didn't
have as much of?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well, Henri
traveled to all these places
that I wanted to go to.
He had a great sense of
composition and shape
and beautiful geometry,
great humanity,
great stories in his
pictures about ordinary life.
And it's very difficult.
It's easy-- not
easy, but it's less--
well, to make a great
picture in your hometown
on the street of
just common life
is a very difficult thing to do.
And then, of course, he had this
great sense of timing and sense
of the decisive moment,
which was a term that he
used to describe his work.
But he had a great
eye, great heart,
and made just great pictures.
And I thought, this
is the kind of work
that really speaks to me.
And this is the kind of
photographer I want to emulate.
PETER FETTERMAN: And when you
finally ended up meeting him,
how was that?
That first meeting,
were you intimidated?
Were you, oh, my god,
I'm meeting Rembrandt?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
I was extremely
intimidated, because I knew
that he could be really tough.
I wouldn't say cruel, but
he could be a bit rude
if he didn't like the work.
So I went to see him and his
wife Martine, took my book.
And I thought, this
is either going
to be the beginning
or the end of my--
PETER FETTERMAN: Career.
STEVE MCCURRY: --career.
And he was very complimentary.
It was just the three of us--
myself, Martine, and Henri.
He had very kind things to say.
We talked about India, because
he had spent a lot of time
there.
And I have to say that I'm
really quite proud to--
in your gallery now, you have
some of my work on the wall.
But you also have a significant
amount of Henri's pictures
on the wall.
PETER FETTERMAN: They seem
to complement each other
very well.
STEVE MCCURRY: Well, I
don't collect photography
by and large.
But the first
photograph I bought
was one of Henri's pictures.
PETER FETTERMAN: Me, too.
That's what got me
addicted to photography.
STEVE MCCURRY: And
this is 20 years ago.
I wish I had bought
more, because it's just,
for me, some of the most
iconic work in photography.
PETER FETTERMAN: Why India?
You spent so much of your
time and your career in India.
What keeps bringing
you back there?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
as I mentioned,
I spent a year in Europe.
I was in Sweden.
I worked in Amsterdam doing odd
jobs, traveled around Europe.
So when I started
my freelance career,
I wanted to go somewhere.
I had been to Africa on
another trip and Latin America.
So I thought, OK, where
can I really launch
this freelance career?
So I thought-- Russia was
difficult at that time
in the late '70s.
China was also a bit
difficult to get into.
So I thought, India.
India's rich, has so many
different cultures, religions,
geography, and disparity
between extreme rich and poor,
between people living in the
ultramodern and people living
in kind of an ancient
way-- living in villages
without electricity and without
running water and all that.
So I thought, I'll go to India.
I'll go for a few weeks.
And then I'll move
to different regions.
So that few week trip
turned into two years.
I literally stayed in
India for two years.
And I was just astonished at
how incredible this country was.
I lived through two monsoons.
I had, as an
11-year-old boy, seen
the work of Brian Brake, who
had done this incredible essay
on the monsoon.
So I had lived
through two monsoons.
I thought, this is
a dramatic moment.
PETER FETTERMAN: Where do you
get your fearlessness from?
You go into these
extraordinary situations.
STEVE MCCURRY: Well, I've
always hated being timid.
I remember in the
monsoon, I tried
to avoid getting into the water.
Because in the water
there are dead animals,
and there was all kinds
of crap in the water.
So I had boots.
And I tried to work from a boat.
And in the end I decided
that if I'm really
going to do this
story in the best way,
I'm going to have to
get into that muck.
So I did that.
I spent days in flooded regions.
PETER FETTERMAN: Do you
do a lot of research
before you go to a
specific location,
or do you just get there
and just breathe the moment?
STEVE MCCURRY: I do a
little bit of research.
I want to know, in general,
the best places to go,
the places that are going
to interest me the most.
But I try not to
over-research, because I always
find I'm disappointed.
I talk about a particular area.
And I'm looking for something.
And I get there, and
it's no longer there.
Things change-- these
guide books and whatever.
So I've decided maybe it's
just better to go cold
and just to discover
things once you get there.
Everything is fresh and new.
PETER FETTERMAN: What strikes
me the most about looking
at your work over
all these years
is the incredible empathy
you have for your subject.
Do you feel a great
responsibility
towards the people
you're photographing?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
I've always felt that we
always need to treat people
with dignity and respect.
And no matter how
poor people look,
we need to try to meet them and
understand how they're living.
And often, you have to break
down that distance between you
and them.
And you have to try and--
so often, photographers--
I see students when
I'm on workshops--
they try and stay at
arm's length to the people
that they're photographing.
I think you really have
to wade in and meet
people and joke with people
and really spend time.
And then I think a
whole world opens up.
PETER FETTERMAN: So
you can't be detached.
You can't be--
STEVE MCCURRY: No,
you have to want
to really get in and literally
meet people, talk to people,
walk into a shop or
restaurant, sit down--
or in a neighborhood and
talk to people on the street.
And even if you don't
have a translator
and you're there by
yourself, you can always--
just by hand gestures or just
by joking around with people.
It's amazing how far you can go
with nonverbal communication--
a smile, something.
You can achieve
everything just by a smile
and by showing people
that you're at their level
and that you're not
some arrogant tourist
with a big camera and a taxi
waiting for you and all that.
PETER FETTERMAN: Many
of your strongest images
have children in them.
Is that a conscious
decision, or are you
just attracted to their
vulnerability, their emotion?
STEVE MCCURRY: I love children.
I think that they're so
innocent, and they're so pure.
And there's no veneer.
They're just there.
And they're happy,
or they're sad.
And often, they're very playful.
And I just think that
working with children
is so much fun,
because they're so--
PETER FETTERMAN: Let's look
at an image of a child.
This is a pretty famous
child in your life.
How did this come about?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
this was at the time
when there were about three
million Afghan refugees living
in Pakistan and Iran.
So I was doing this
story on the border
of Pakistan, Afghanistan.
And one morning, I
wandered through the camp.
It was about 11 o'clock.
I was almost on the verge
of quitting and going back
to the hotel and having lunch.
PETER FETTERMAN:
You were frustrated.
You didn't see anything.
STEVE MCCURRY: I
wasn't frustrated,
but the light was really harsh.
I'd already been there
for three or four hours.
And I thought, let me take
a break, because it was hot
and the sun's really bright.
I don't like to work
in really bright light.
So as I was walking
through the camp,
I noticed these voices
coming from a tent.
It was a school.
So I wandered over.
I thought, maybe I'll check
this out before I head out.
So this girls' school--
so I looked in.
And the first thing I
noticed off in the corner
was this little girl
with this incredible look
and these amazing eyes.
So I asked the teacher if I
could come in, photograph.
So I had a permit.
I had permission.
And she told me to come in.
But I knew that the
main objective was
to get a picture of this girl.
PETER FETTERMAN: So it
was love at first sight.
There was an instant.
You saw something really
special about this kid and not
the other 50 kids there.
STEVE MCCURRY: I said, there is
an incredible portrait there.
So what I did was I thought--
because if I go right to her,
she might get too
shy and refuse--
lost.
So I decided to photograph
some of the other students,
almost to the point where
she would feel excluded.
And so eventually,
I came around and--
PETER FETTERMAN: You
used child psychology.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
That's it exactly.
Yeah.
So I finally came to her.
So she came and sat down
in front of my lens.
PETER FETTERMAN: Never
seen a camera, I presume?
STEVE MCCURRY: Never seen a
camera, never met a foreigner,
and had no idea
about photography.
I think part of the look is
curiosity, maybe wondering, who
am I, who is this
photographer, why is he dressed
in a funny way, and what kind
of language is he speaking,
and what is this
camera, and all that.
So I took maybe
10 or 15 pictures.
And at first, she was a bit shy.
She had her hands
up to her face.
And the teacher
explained to her,
we've got to cooperate
with this guy,
because he's telling
our story to the world,
because our village has
been destroyed, et cetera.
So then she dropped her hands.
And I shifted my
camera off to the side
to get better light on her face,
which was natural light coming
from outside the tent.
And I took just a few pictures.
And as I was in the middle
of the most important shoot
of my life, she got up and
thought, OK, that was fun.
That's over.
PETER FETTERMAN: When you
create an image like this
that has this universal appeal,
acceptance, iconic stature,
do you feel you have to
live up to create something
as great as that every
time you start to shoot?
Is it a burden as
well as a blessing?
STEVE MCCURRY:
I've only ever seen
it as positive and completely
humbled and grateful
that I was able to
make this picture.
And it's due mostly to her for--
PETER FETTERMAN: Well,
it's due to you perceiving
that she had something special
and that connects with people.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
PETER FETTERMAN: It's one
of the most famous photos
in the 20th century
history, isn't it?
STEVE MCCURRY: If
you say so, yeah.
PETER FETTERMAN:
Along with D-Day.
STEVE MCCURRY: But just to--
if you could go back.
I don't know if you can go back.
It's one of these cases where
everything lined up perfectly.
The stars were in a
complete alignment--
the background, the
color of the background,
the green shawl had a nice
complementary color to it.
And everything was just perfect.
And it just happened
that way, and the light
happened to be just right.
PETER FETTERMAN: Why
do you feel everybody
connected to it in a way that
was pretty unprecedented?
STEVE MCCURRY: I think it's
because she's very pretty,
but there's a look which is very
direct, very almost haunted.
You can tell that
she's a bit poor
but that she has this
incredible dignity to her.
And she's going to power through
whatever problems she has.
I think even if you don't
know that she's a refugee,
I still think there is a
power to her expression.
PETER FETTERMAN:
You connect to it,
and you feel her vulnerability,
and it's very humbling.
As is this photo,
this is probably
my favorite photo of yours.
How did this come about?
STEVE MCCURRY: I was on my
way to my hotel in Bombay.
On the way from the
airport, there's
probably 50 traffic lights you
have to go through to get--
and at each traffic
light, often there's
people who come up
and ask for money.
And this woman came
up with her child.
And she was looking in
through this fogged window.
And she's looking at me,
and I'm looking at her.
And I just instinctually
took two exposures.
And then the light changed.
And we sped off.
But it's this two worlds.
She's in the traffic and
the heat and the rain.
And I'm in this air
conditioned bubble.
And it's just for that moment
we had this connection.
And the color works, in
terms of the picture.
And this little
child's looking at me.
PETER FETTERMAN: What's the
saddest situation you've ever
found yourself in
after all these years?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well, probably
working in these refugee camps,
whether it was in Lebanon
or Kashmir or Sri Lanka
or Thailand or Lebanon, Syria.
These are places where
these people have lived,
maybe had a very happy life.
I know in Afghanistan people had
very large homes in the village
and had a really wonderful life.
And then there's these camps.
And they're suddenly stuck in
a tent and crammed together.
And their whole way of life
is uprooted and basically has
been destroyed.
So I can't imagine
what it would be
like to be driven from your
home and then have to go live
in a foreign country and just
live at the mercy of people's
charity.
PETER FETTERMAN: Do
you feel you have
to emotionally detach
yourself at times in order
to take the photograph?
STEVE MCCURRY: It's
hard to do that.
But I do think you
have to remind yourself
that this is an
important story that
needs to be shown to the world.
Their story has
to get out there.
People need to be
informed about what's
going on in our world,
like Syria, for instance.
And without people
to tell that story,
these people are voiceless.
So that has to be
more important than--
PETER FETTERMAN: Whatever
you're particularly
feeling at that moment?
STEVE MCCURRY: Exactly.
That's right.
Yeah.
So I think that's the toughest--
PETER FETTERMAN: This seems
a happy situation for you.
Was it?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
And as a wandering
street photographer,
often you come around a corner
and you see a composition.
Photographers have been doing
this for the last 100 years.
But you recognize that as
people are coming and going
from this composition that
the person or an animal
or whatever that comes
through completes the picture.
So in this case,
it just so happened
that in India, after this
festival called Holi,
somebody put all these
handprints on the wall.
And this was a very
well-traveled alleyway.
And there were people
coming and going.
There were vendors.
There were cows.
So I just stood there,
and I was photographing
people coming into my frame and
people going out of my frame.
I stood there for, I don't
know, maybe an hour, maybe
an hour and a half, maybe more.
And then went back at night and
started looking at my pictures
and decided, I think
this has great potential.
So I went back
again the next day
and spent another bit of time.
But again, the colors and
that edge of the okra,
just I thought it
was a great moment.
PETER FETTERMAN: In everything
you've photographed,
did you feel the human spirit
is essentially good or bad?
STEVE MCCURRY: I think
it's basically good.
There's a lot of evil forces
and bad actors out there.
But I think that basically
you meet people on the street,
and people are generally
kind and hospitable
and willing to be photographed.
Wherever I've gone in the
world, nine times out of 10,
if you approach
people with a smile,
people are more
than happy to agree
to have their portrait taken.
PETER FETTERMAN: Has there ever
been a situation where you just
couldn't take the
photograph because what
you were in front of was
so emotionally disturbing?
STEVE MCCURRY: That
only happened one time.
PETER FETTERMAN: Where was that?
STEVE MCCURRY: That was on
the banks of the Ganges.
And it's very common for
people to be cremated.
And sometimes they can't
afford to be cremated.
They just throw their
bodies into the river.
And there were some dogs.
And I thought,
whoa, I can't even
look at that, let
alone photograph it.
So I walked away from that.
But again, treating people--
always being respectful.
I think you need
to make the picture
and then decide
afterward whether you
should pass it along and print
it or publish it or whatever.
But I always am very
respectful of people's--
if there's a funeral,
if there's a death,
I think you have to be
really, really careful
and not overstep
that line where you--
PETER FETTERMAN: It
might be in bad taste,
as we say in the first world.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah, bad taste.
And this may be the most
tragic moment of their life.
And you just have to be
very respectful of that
and evaluate moment to moment--
is this the right thing to do?
Should I make this picture?
Sometimes they want
you to photograph them,
because they want
that story told.
But sometimes they don't.
So you just have to be able
to read that situation.
PETER FETTERMAN: So you're
always walking on a moral line.
STEVE MCCURRY: Every moment.
One moment, it could be
the right thing to do.
And then things shift,
and you have to adjust.
So your internal
computer's always
readjusting and recalibrating.
PETER FETTERMAN:
Another magical image--
how did this come about?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
as I say, I was really
inspired by Brian Brake,
because the monsoon was
such a dramatic weather event.
It was either too much rain and
you had floods, or not enough
and you had drought.
And people living in these
agricultural countries really
depend on the rain.
It's no joke.
So I went to India weeks
before the onset of the rain,
because I wanted to get the
build-up of the heat, the dust,
the hot wind, which is the
prelude to the monsoon.
And so I was driving to the
desert going between, I think,
Jodhpur and Jaisalmer, and this
enormous dust storm came up out
of nowhere.
And my first inclination was to
roll the windows up of the car
and try and hunker down.
So I didn't want to
get my cameras dusty.
Then I realized,
wait a minute, I'm
actually supposed to
be shooting all this.
So then I started looking
around for something
to photograph, some people.
And then as I was
getting desperate,
I saw these women, who had
been working, huddled together.
PETER FETTERMAN: What
were they working at?
What were they doing?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
during the dry season,
just before the
monsoon, the government
has these programs where they
employ thousands of villagers
to work on the road or dig--
PETER FETTERMAN: It's
like a WPA project.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
So they were doing this work.
And they were huddled
together, I guess,
just because it was
windy and dusty.
And I ran across the field.
I made a few pictures.
And then the wind stopped.
And they went back to
work, and it was over.
So you can't hesitate.
You have to seize the moment.
PETER FETTERMAN: I
have to thank you,
because you turned me
on to color photography.
I was a terrible black and
white snob before I met you.
And you just can't conceive
of these images we've been
looking at in black and white.
They just wouldn't have the
power and the luminosity
and the impact.
So I thank you for
turning me on to color.
What's going on here?
STEVE MCCURRY:
Well, I always felt
it was more logical
to photograph
in color, because the
world is in color.
And so much of the
story, if you go
to a Tibetan monastery or Hindu
temple, a lot of the cultural--
it's so much cultural
information in color.
So it makes more sense for me to
photograph the world in color.
So I was in Burma
on the west coast.
There was this ship
that had run aground.
So you had this really surreal
situation where these children
are playing with a ball.
There's this ship
that's run aground.
And it was actually really heavy
rain when I took this picture.
But you can't see the
rain, because it's--
you need a dark background
to see the water.
But I just thought it was these
children floating out there.
And the surf was only
a couple inches deep.
And they're playing
there, having a great time
during the monsoon, and
not a care in the world.
It looked like so much fun.
PETER FETTERMAN: Would you say
it's a happy photo for you?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
I like dark, moody pictures.
I've always been
attracted more to the--
for color, the color's muted,
dark, more low contrast.
For me, it works
better than bright sun.
I never work in the bright sun.
Yeah.
I'm actually very
proud of this picture.
This picture no longer exists.
There's no more steam
locomotives in India.
PETER FETTERMAN: What are
they now, all diesel trains?
STEVE MCCURRY:
They're all, I guess,
diesel or electric or whatever.
And that particular
track has been ripped up.
And it's gone.
So although the railroad
yard still exists there
and there are trains that
go back and forth many times
a day, that particular
track is gone.
And the steam engines are gone.
But this juxtaposition between
the Taj Mahal and the train,
I thought, was great.
I spent some time with Paul
Theroux, the great travel
writer--
just a great writer in general.
And we did this journey
from the Khyber Pass
through Pakistan, India,
and into Bangladesh.
PETER FETTERMAN: Did he
suggest images along the way
as you were chatting?
Or through your
conversations, did that
spark a direction to go in?
STEVE MCCURRY: I
never need a writer
to suggest images for me.
PETER FETTERMAN:
You're self-generating.
STEVE MCCURRY:
But I have to say,
I was inspired to do this
story based on his book,
"The Great Railway
Bazaar," which
I had read when I was
in bed with dysentery,
getting rabies shots
at the same time.
I was delirious.
But that book was so delightful
and such a great read.
And then five years later,
meeting him and then recreating
this particular
leg of the journey,
I thought, was great fun.
PETER FETTERMAN: Which
movies have inspired you?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well, I
think "Sunset Boulevard."
I'd see that over
and over again.
And it was filmed right
here in Los Angeles.
But all the work of Kubrick--
of course, I always loved
Charlie Chaplin's movies,
"Goodfellas."
PETER FETTERMAN: Little
bit of violence thrown in.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
I take all of my own movies
on the plane on my iPad.
PETER FETTERMAN: So
that's how you relax.
STEVE MCCURRY: That's
how I relax, absolutely.
Yeah.
PETER FETTERMAN: And other
great books you've read that--
STEVE MCCURRY:
The Coen brothers,
they had the "O Caesar" that
just came out and "O Brother."
I read a book recently by
Fawn Brodie on the life
and times of Sir Richard
Francis Burton, who
was a 19th century
British explorer who
spoke 25 languages.
PETER FETTERMAN: Do you identify
with that kind of travel lust?
STEVE MCCURRY: No, no.
He lived in another time and
did it in a much more grand way.
But he lived in India.
He lived in Syria,
South America.
He traveled to the US.
He spoke all these
languages flawlessly--
Arabic, Hindi, plus all
the European languages.
Tried to find the
source of the Nile--
so he had an incredible-- that
kind of adventure now no longer
exists, because I think
now we get upset--
he was actually
walking from Zanzibar
close to Lake Victoria.
PETER FETTERMAN: What do you
think drove him on to do that
against all those odds?
STEVE MCCURRY: I
think he was crazy.
PETER FETTERMAN:
You think you're
a bit crazy to put yourself
in these situations?
STEVE MCCURRY: You think,
I'm still a young man.
But why would you go to
crawl through the muck now
when I don't have to?
PETER FETTERMAN: So
what's the answer?
STEVE MCCURRY: I could
go live on a beach and--
PETER FETTERMAN: You're
a very successful guy.
You could--
STEVE MCCURRY:
--smoke a good cigar.
PETER FETTERMAN: --as we were
talking in the car coming over,
you could retire.
What keeps you driving?
What is it?
STEVE MCCURRY: I think it's
simply loving what you do.
I get great pleasure
and great fulfillment
out of making pictures.
The whole process of
walking down the street
and discovering things
is a great pleasure.
And I think that I can
never imagine just retiring
and to do what?
Retire from what you love?
Can you imagine
Picasso saying, I
think I've painted
enough pictures,
I'm going to just go relax now?
I think this is
what energizes me
and what gives great
purpose to my life.
And I'm still excited
about going to new places
and going back to old places.
I've been to Italy.
I'm going back to
Italy in about a week.
PETER FETTERMAN: Do you think
you're getting better at this?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah, I think
you have to believe that.
PETER FETTERMAN: Otherwise
you can't get out of bed.
STEVE MCCURRY: No.
But I think that as you
perfect your craft--
how you see light.
I've photographed
for 40-plus years.
And I've photographed--
not everything,
but I kind of feel like I've
photographed everything.
And I think you want to
photograph things in new ways.
And I think then you're
starting to do better work,
because you've run
through all the cliches.
Now you're trying to
maybe up your game a bit.
So I think I'm doing as
good of work or better.
I think digital
photography actually--
PETER FETTERMAN:
Makes it easier?
STEVE MCCURRY: --make
a big improvement,
because I've always
gravitated towards low light,
dark corners.
And with digital, you can
really work in that low light,
whereas with film
it was impossible.
So often, I remember you're
in a really dark situation,
and you're shooting.
You think, oh, this
is a great picture.
I'm really happy.
You get home a
month later and you
realize all the pictures
are back-focused.
You thought you were in focus.
But in fact, you
missed the focus.
But with digital, at some
point, you can check.
Because if it's dark, you can
check and say, oh, my god,
I'm not in focus.
PETER FETTERMAN: Are
there any drawbacks
to shooting in digital?
Is there anything you miss
about the analog life you had?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
I think the only tricky part
is the storage and having
to have multiple backups.
Because you put your
pictures on a hard drive,
it goes in a drawer.
You come back to it
5, 10, 15 years later,
and maybe the hard
drive is degraded.
Maybe something happened to it.
Maybe you can't
read it any longer,
because you don't
have the right cords.
There's all sorts of things.
So you have to be really careful
that your work is backed up.
And we have a great system
in multiple locations
just for that very reason.
PETER FETTERMAN: As
a man of the world,
what's your biggest fear
for the future of humanity?
STEVE MCCURRY: I think
we're on the right track.
I'm just not sure we're going
to get there soon enough.
Let's ask that question of
the elephants and the tigers.
What do they think about the
state of the world right now?
I think they would
be like, oh, my god,
the world's coming to an end.
So we know that in the case
of wildlife, they're in peril,
and it's a dire situation.
And I think more
people care today
about that or climate change
or the oceans or whatever.
Just a question
of-- are we going
to move fast enough to
actually make a difference
or to save the planet?
We all hope so, but I
think it's not a done deal.
PETER FETTERMAN:
Well, we're being
hosted by one of the
great technology companies
in the world.
If you can have one
wish, what would you
wish that a company
like this could do now
of all that you've seen?
STEVE MCCURRY: I think the
more people are connected
and the more they have access
to information and education,
health care, I think
that this will be a far--
when people have
that information,
their lives will be better.
And I think people will
tend to come together,
hopefully, and respect
each other's cultures.
I think that's important.
PETER FETTERMAN:
So we're hopeful,
even though we turn
on the television
and we look at
what's going on now?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah, there's
a lot of reason to be--
PETER FETTERMAN: Despair.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
But I think we've
got to power through.
There's no option.
We have to move forward.
PETER FETTERMAN: Well, you've
given us a lot of hope,
and your images connect us.
Maybe it's a good time
to ask some questions.
STEVE MCCURRY: Everybody
has to ask one question.
We're going to go
around the room.
PETER FETTERMAN: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
I really admire your work a lot.
And I'm just so
grateful you're here.
So I had a question-- one
related to shooting style
or your approach to shooting.
So I know with
Bresson, I think what
he would do is he would
set his focus in advance
and his exposure.
And he'd walk around,
without even looking
through the
viewfinder sometimes,
and just wait for
everything to come together,
and then shoot at
the decisive moment.
For shots that you take that
look unplanned or unposed,
how many of those
are you shooting
without looking
through the viewfinder
and just waiting for a moment
or it just comes up to you?
Like the people
coming up to the cab,
it looked like maybe
you weren't even looking
through the viewfinder.
You just had the camera
here and shot it.
Or were you looking
through the viewfinder?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah, I always
look through the viewfinder.
He had an uncanny ability
to make really good pictures
holding his camera up.
But the advantage we have
now over photographing
in the '40s or the '50s is
that we have auto-focus now.
We can work at a
much higher ISO.
Where he may have
been at 200 or 100,
I can shoot it at
1,000 or 2,000.
So we can get much
sharper pictures.
But I think that I don't
do so well when I don't
look through the viewfinder.
I need to see the picture.
AUDIENCE: And have you ever
written about your experiences
in India when you were there
those first couple years?
STEVE MCCURRY: There may
be something in this--
PETER FETTERMAN: There's
a lot of great information
about Steve's process in
this wonderful book called--
STEVE MCCURRY: "Untold."
PETER FETTERMAN: --"Untold."
Should we hold it up?
I will hold it.
Thank you so much
for loaning it.
I think this is a great
insight into what it takes
to be a great photographer.
And I think this is
probably the first time
you articulated
many of the things
that you said today in print.
So if you want to
know more of what
it takes to be a
great photographer,
I would recommend this book,
"Untold," Steve McCurry.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PETER FETTERMAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: There was a
story a few years ago
where a team from
National Geographic
went back to
Afghanistan or Pakistan
to find the girl in the photo.
And I believe they
found her in a village.
Were you part of that team?
And did you talk with her?
Or what was your experience
going back to her
or see her 20 years
later or whatever it was?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
I was part of that documentary.
We had gotten thousands
of letters over the years.
People wanting to know--
where is she, how can we
help her, is she still alive?
They wanted to send her money.
Men wanted to marry her.
It was incredible.
So just after 9/11,
when people started
to learn about
Afghanistan, we decided
to go and try and find her.
And we had no idea
where she was.
We didn't know her name.
So I thought, well, let's
go back to the refugee camp
where I had photographed her.
And I just knew there
was no way we were ever
going to locate her.
But we got very lucky.
And after a few days,
we found the teacher
who had been in the
classroom that day.
And then another week went by.
Somebody came up and said, I
know where her brother lives.
And then we thought, well, it
could be they're wanting money.
I thought, OK, that's
just the story.
But lo and behold, he
actually found the brother.
And of course, once we found the
brother, we were able to find--
PETER FETTERMAN: How long did
it take you to find her again?
STEVE MCCURRY: About two weeks.
PETER FETTERMAN:
And there were times
when you wanted to give up.
You thought, this is
futile, what am I doing?
STEVE MCCURRY: There
were so many people
who were pretending
to be her and saying,
oh, it's great to see you.
PETER FETTERMAN:
Like fake Elvis's.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
And they would swear up and
down that they were the girl
and they remembered everything.
And there was one who
everybody was convinced--
even the filmmaker,
he got on the phone
and was calling all
these eye doctors
around the world
saying, is it possible
that her eyes could
go from the way they
were in the picture to brown?
He's waking up doctors in
the middle of the night.
One of the doctors said,
well, it's possible,
there could be a shift.
And they took that
and just ran with it.
They thought for sure.
So we went down
the road really far
with her, in terms of
interviewing her and all that.
PETER FETTERMAN: It must
have been pretty emotional
for both of you.
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
when we actually
met her and she walked
through the door,
I was literally expecting--
half thinking that it was going
to be the same little girl
walking through the door.
PETER FETTERMAN:
Time had stopped.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
And this is 17 years later.
Now she's a grown woman.
She's a mother.
She's married.
And she was dressed in black.
It was a rather dark room.
And this figure walked in.
And I thought, whoa, I
wasn't expecting that.
But she was healthy.
And as I said, she had a family.
And we quickly,
within the same day,
we started talking about,
how can we help you?
What can we do to
make your life better?
But in that culture,
to be able to meet her,
photograph her is a complete
impossibility, because women
are not supposed to
be seen by somebody
outside of their families.
PETER FETTERMAN: So how did you
negotiate your way around it?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well, we
had a great translator
who happened to be a very
respected journalist.
We had his help.
Her husband-- we had to get the
permission from the husband--
agreed to let us meet her.
And I think they trusted us.
I think they felt
that this was going
to be a good thing for them.
And I was able to photograph
her, which never happens.
So it was a great story to--
PETER FETTERMAN: And was
she aware of the impact
that the original photo
had had on the world?
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
she is illiterate.
So she wasn't aware.
She didn't get
magazines or newspapers
and had no idea that her
picture was famous and published
all over the world.
And she didn't know that.
She thought that, well,
there's that one copy.
But then we explained it.
And then when the
documentary came out,
we made sure she had access to
a television so she could see,
because the story ran
all over the world.
And so since then,
we've been continuing
to be in touch with her and
help her in all possible ways.
AUDIENCE: I have a question more
about your current projects.
I know there's a lot of
tumultuous situations
around the world-- the Syrian
refugee crisis, for example.
What are you
currently working on?
Are you involved in that at all?
I'm just more interested in
what you're currently doing.
STEVE MCCURRY: Well,
my work has really
shifted away from magazines.
And I'm doing more
personal projects.
At this point in my
life, I want to do
exactly what I want to do.
I want to have fun and do things
that I think are interesting.
PETER FETTERMAN: Come here and
talk and explain your work.
STEVE MCCURRY: Exactly.
Yeah.
So I think it's important
to evolve and grow and do
different things in your life.
So now I'm interested
in books, exhibitions,
like with Peter in the gallery.
And I want to go places.
And I have a book coming
out in a few weeks on people
reading around the world.
It's a interesting little book.
I just have a book on
India that came out.
And I want to have other
projects I want to do.
And I just want to go to
places and be involved
with situations
and my nonprofit,
helping children in Afghanistan.
So this is how I want to spend--
I want to just do
exactly what I think
is the most important
thing for me right now.
AUDIENCE: You deserve it.
STEVE MCCURRY: Thank you.
PETER FETTERMAN: If there
was one word to describe you,
or somebody else
describing you, what
would that word be,
apart from crazy?
STEVE MCCURRY:
Energetic, passionate.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: So I love your work.
And as an Indian who spent
all of six years in India,
I live vicariously
through your pictures.
And so I had a question.
I go back to that part of
the world every few years.
And it changes
every time I'm back.
And you mentioned
something about the fact
that you photographed something,
then you come back to it,
and it changes.
Have you ever felt in going back
that it's changed in some way?
And what are your
thoughts on how
it's changed and transformed
through the years?
STEVE MCCURRY: Right.
By the way, my book on India
is purely my point of view.
And in my book, I'm
not really trying
to tell the story of India.
It's more like a diary,
my personal impressions.
India's a vast country
with so much going on.
My book is more just
personal impressions,
little moments in time.
And it's nothing more than that.
I'm not trying to
say, this is India.
That's impossible
to do in one book.
But India, when I first arrived
in '78, there was no internet.
Making phone calls--
there was no cell phones.
To book a call back home would
take sometimes hours and hours.
Sometimes it never went through.
I shipped film back by the post.
Now you can send
them wirelessly.
Or there was FedEx for a while.
But there was a time when
I would send my film,
literally mail it back.
But with all the internet
and whatnot, people in India
now have access to
all the information.
I used to walk
through a village,
and children used to follow me,
because I was like a novelty--
had a camera and
was this foreigner.
And now children,
they've seen it all.
And they're not fascinated
with a foreigner with a camera,
because they've seen better
on their video games.
So back when I first went to
India, the cars on the street,
there were two or three,
mostly made in India.
Now they have all the cars--
Mercedes.
You can get everything.
PETER FETTERMAN: Could you
still take this photo today?
STEVE MCCURRY: This
one from Calcutta?
PETER FETTERMAN: Has
it changed that much?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah,
that's still pretty much
the way it is.
I love Calcutta.
If somebody said,
here's a blank check,
go to a city in the world and
do a book or an exhibition,
I'd go to Calcutta.
PETER FETTERMAN: Because?
STEVE MCCURRY: It's so rich.
First of all, there's great art.
And the arts in West Bengal
and Calcutta are very rich.
Filmmaking, photography--
they have great festivals
there, great spirit.
And there's this vibrancy on
the street which is unmatched,
I think, any place in the world.
So I'm a big fan of Calcutta.
And yeah, this
was a street scene
there that it was
just incredible.
Back when I first
went there, there
was a limited amount of
access to certain products.
So now everything is available.
And all the tech
companies are there.
The automobile
And they're really
taking over the world.
PETER FETTERMAN: We
have another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank
you for being here.
So having the opportunity
to travel the world,
you've seen multiple
humanitarian issues.
And I appreciate you
sharing them with the world
and being able to have that
action impact that way.
But I'm just wondering, what
causes and humanitarian issues
do you take away as being
most important to you
that you're actively
focusing on?
I know that you mentioned
having a nonprofit.
Can you tell me a little bit
more about those efforts there?
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
In the past, we've sent
textbooks to Bamyan Province
and supported
teachers and whatnot.
Now we've shifted.
My sister is very
active in this.
We're actually organizing
cameras and photography classes
for young Afghan girls--
give them a chance to have
a different experience,
have a creative outlet,
photograph their friends,
family, their community,
and to just have
this artistic endeavor.
So that's where
we're at with that.
And we're in Bamyan Province,
in Kabul, and in Herat.
And some of the
pictures are really
wonderful that these
young girls are making.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STEVE MCCURRY: Thank you.
PETER FETTERMAN:
Any more questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I guess a related follow-up
question would be,
have you ever found yourself
in certain situations
where there was a
humanitarian crisis
and it was really difficult
for you personally
to keep your journalistic
distance from the subject?
I'm sure you've been
approached a lot--
with the woman in that photo--
to ask for money.
And how do you negotiate
those conversations?
And I was just wondering if
you could speak more to that.
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah.
When I was in
Cambodia, when there
were hundreds of
thousands of Cambodians
flooding into Thailand,
things were a bit tense.
And they would come up to us
or to me and say, can you help?
One guy came up to me and
said, I have some gold,
can you take it
back into Thailand
and exchange it for money?
And they were really desperate.
And you do the best you can.
I took the gold, and I
changed it and all that.
But you try and help
in any way you can.
But I would say that in
my experience, by the time
I get to these places,
the Red Cross and UNHCR
and a lot of the relief
agencies are already there.
And everything's
pretty much set up.
So in my experience,
by the time I show up,
everything's pretty
much already organized.
But still you can
help in small ways.
PETER FETTERMAN:
Well, thank you.
Thank you, Google, for all
your-- oh, you have a question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
And you started your talk
about-- you mentioned
some fine lines when
you take a picture
or sometimes you decide
not to take it, step away.
You decide to publish
it or not to publish,
to post-process and how
much to post-process.
In your 40-plus
years experience,
do those lines change?
Do you regret today not
taking certain pictures
or the opposite-- maybe you
published certain pictures that
you today wouldn't?
How much would you
change if anything?
And maybe a related
question is, do you
have any unpublished
pictures and why?
Why wouldn't you
publish if you do?
STEVE MCCURRY: I have
hundreds of thousands
of unpublished pictures.
I would be delighted to
publish those pictures.
Some pictures are
better than others.
No.
I think that we all have
unpublished pictures.
And maybe some
unpublished pictures
are better unseen,
because you want pictures
to come up to a certain--
PETER FETTERMAN: Do you
think you're the best
judge of what is your--
STEVE MCCURRY: No.
I know you mentioned the picture
by Andre Cartier-Bresson which
had gone unnoticed largely.
And you saw it, liked it, and
asked to have a print made.
And it's a wonderful,
beautiful picture.
I think it's incredible.
It's in your gallery.
So I think that
there's a reason why.
I think you want your
best work published.
And I can't think
of a situation where
I took pictures
which I regretted
or got published and regretted.
I can't really think of many.
There is one instance that comes
to mind where in Bangladesh--
I think it was during
the War of Independence--
there were some
photographers who were there.
And there were these
soldiers that were maybe
encouraged by the press.
And there's this
famous picture--
won a Pulitzer Prize-- which
the soldiers bayoneting
this poor person,
probably to death.
And maybe if the press
had walked away, maybe
that person wouldn't have--
but in the heat of the moment,
things happen.
This is a long
time-- generally, I
would say most of my colleagues,
they are compassionate people
and want to do the right thing.
So there's always something
that goes sideways.
But I think in general things
either do the right thing.
So I don't have any situations
like that that I regret taking.
PETER FETTERMAN: Well,
hopefully, maybe we'll
get invited back
by Google and we
can have Steve McCurry,
the unseen photos.
And you'll be the first people
in the world to see them.
But thank you all for coming.
Thank you, Benjamin,
for hosting this.
Thank you, Steve.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE MCCURRY: Yeah,
thank you very much.
It was a great
pleasure to be here.
Thank you.